move away from that report to take you
live to Washington DC to listen in to
the U.S President Joe Biden speaking
about the shooting in Nashville
and we do know that as of now there are
a number of people who are not going to
did not make it
including children
it's heartbreaking a family's worst
nightmare
and I want to commend the police who
respond respond incredibly swiftly
within minutes and the danger
we're monitoring this situation really
closely Ben as you know and we have to
do more to stop gun violence it's
ripping our communities apart ripping a
soul this nation and ripping at the very
soul of the nation
and we we have to do more to protect our
schools so they aren't turned into
prisons
you know a shooter in this situation
reportedly had two assault weapons and a
pistol to ak-47.
so I call on Congress again to pass my
assault weapons ban it's about time that
we began to make some more progress but
there's more to learn but I just wanted
to send my uh
concern hearts out to so many parents
out there
I've been to so many of these sites as
Ben knows but virtually every one
and uh one of the things you folks
should I know you do know what you
should focus on
you know just like when
in the military my son was in Iraq for
your other places you
there's so many
members of the military coming back with
post-traumatic stress after witnessing
the violence and participating in it
for these children
these teachers
you should be should be focusing on
their mental health as well
and so I'm grateful anyway
sorry to start off that way but I
couldn't begin without an acknowledging
what happened
and now I'm grateful all of you are
joining us here today Natalie thank you
for that introduction
and for doing such an amazing thing in
Detroit
Detroit making change charges for
electric vehicles in the Motor City
keeping going during the pandemic and I
want to welcome your son D op where's
DIA
all right we're moving away from the U.S
presidents he was speaking at an event
in Washington D.C but he did touch upon
the uh breaking news story in the past
hour that there's been another shooting
in the United States this happening at a
school in Nashville in Tennessee we
understand that at least six people have
been killed in the shooter was a woman
who used two assault rifles let's bring
in our White House correspondent
Kimberly halcott so the President says
he's closely monitoring the situation
and once again saying the U.S must do
more to stop gun violence Kimberly
that's right this is an issue that is
something the U.S president has worked
on for an enormous amount of time you'll
recall that this is something that he
campaigned on as president and is once
again redoubling his efforts to put in
place an assault weapons ban it's one
that he put in place as a U.S senator it
was in place for 10 years he says it was
very effective but then it expired and
so with each shooting that has occurred
in the United States the U.S president
once again saying this is something that
he is calling on Congress to do it's
important to note why does he always say
call on Congress well the reason he does
that is because laws are not made at the
White House they're made in the U.S
Congress so the president is essentially
powerless he can put in place executive
orders but they're very limited in scale
and scope and so in order to have the
teeth in order to have the power that
the president needs to scale back the
ability for people to acquire the heavy
Weaponry that have been responsible for
so many any of these mass shootings and
school shootings that have occurred in
the United States including this latest
one that has occurred in a Nashville
school where we know three children
three adults dead and also the female
suspect it requires an act of Congress
and up until now that has been proving
to be very challenging because up until
now the powers of a very large Lobby
known as the National Rifle Association
has been lobbying members of Congress
mostly Republican to limit the ability
to sort of allow for Americans to have
these firearms and that many are
defending that right given it's in the
Second Amendment known as the right to
bear arms and so this has been the
challenge for the U.S president but once
again you hear him making these
impromptu marks the top of a business
Summit for women to once again call
attention to the tragedy and once again
call on Congress to do its job he says
in order to save lives yeah
all right Kimberly thank you so much
Kimberly halcott reporting from the
White House